[Music]
midway upon the journey of my life
i found myself within a dark castle
for the straightforward pathway had been
lost
[Music]
strange
i have to uncover the mystery of this
place
and these odd artifacts
[Music]
these tones are hundreds of years old
perhaps older
[Music]
empty all the pages are blank it doesn't
make sense
boom it's halloween i'm bored what are
you doing let's go trick or
oh it's just you organism9186 of course
it's me i've been stuck here ever since
you destroyed my homeworld and
exterminated my species
are you really still upset about that
organism look we're gonna be here a
little bit longer i have to find out
more about this weird uncle of mine
and why he left me this weird place and
this weird box full of strange objects
let's go trick-or-treating okay first of
all organism
there's a pandemic no one is going
trick-or-treating second off
you are an alien creature no one knows
that you exist except for me
if i let you outside it would cause a
total panic
and then third you're an energy being of
pure energy and light you can't even
digest candy what's in the box
what's in the box like i said a bunch of
weird stuff my estranged uncle left me
in his will along with this house
there's artifacts and all these weird
books you can check it out with me if
you want i was bored as soon as you said
books i'm out of here i'm gonna go
recalibrate my plasma tendrils all right
whatever just don't go too far
i guess i'll just make a youtube video
then
petrificus cotales when guardium
[Music]
oh you guys are already here i hope i
didn't freak you guys out too much i'm
just going through my dead relatives
things
a bunch of items were left to me
apparently and i even got this crazy
house some of the stuff is pretty cool
actually like there's this cool pocket
watch
and there's this neat hourglass i've
always wanted one of these
but then look at this silly wand thing i
mean this guy think he was a wizard or
something
and then there's this cane slash staff
thing i mean how ridiculous
i mean really dude calm down and also
rest in peace
you know there's been some weird things
happening around this house
i've been hearing odd noises but i'm
sure it's just
an old house being old i guess i mean i
personally don't believe in ghosts or
spirits or anything
i guess the coolest thing my uncle left
me were these old books
i thought they might be old history
books or something but weirdly enough
though they're clearly very very old
there's nothing written in them
[Music]
that did not just happen
i'm seeing things that's it i'm
definitely seeing things
organism organism 9186
is that you
old house being an old house and there's
also
this weird statue
i don't like it very much
but something about it looks
so familiar
[Music]
it reminds me of something from an old
story it's it's right on the tip of my
tongue
wait a second this looks just like the
creature
from hp lovecraft's the call of cthulhu
and come to think of it this whole
situation the dead
uncle the artifacts the the books
it's almost like i'm inside of a
lovecraft
no no lovecraft wrote fiction lovecraft
i'm not inside of a lovecraft story
lovecraft
is fiction at least i hope lovecraft is
fiction there's so many stories i would
rather be in
other than a lovecraft story for
multiple reasons but
i guess the main one is things don't
ever turn out good
for the protagonist in lovecraft stories
or at least almost never
or just calm yourself down quinn calm
yourself down
lovecraft wrote fiction i mean the short
story the call of cthulhu is one of the
scariest and most enduring horror
stories of all time but
lovecraft was writing fiction he wasn't
channeling anything that was real
no true horrors or was he
you know what it's a good thing i always
keep a copy of the lovecraft compendium
on hand
i need to find out what happens in this
story
it's the only thing that can help me out
of this sticky situation
i can't shake the feeling that bad
things are gonna happen guys
i have no choice i've gotta do a
halloween special
[Music]
the cosmos is endless it is sprawling
beyond comprehension
science tells us that the universe is
mostly empty
made up of distant stretches of vast
silent emptiness
with only star systems passing by
swiftly
only to return into the void galaxies
themselves even are silent wanderers
separated by incomprehensible cosmic
gulfs
with all we know now the wise are aware
of the fact that we have
merely observed an infinitesimally small
portion of our universe lovecraft's
cosmic horror
filled the gaps in our knowledge of the
universe
with unspeakable terrors he wrote of
things wandering through the dark
things so great so beyond our reasoning
or understanding
that perhaps they wouldn't even see us
as living beings ourselves
or even be bothered by our presences
enough to consider us
nuisances but in the call of cthulhu
the horror does not await in distant
space
it is not bound to another realm of
existence
only able to cross over when summoned by
the necronomicon
cthulhu slept beneath the very ocean
itself
in 1997 scientists recorded one of the
loudest underwater sounds ever to occur
it became known as the bloop researchers
at the national oceanic atmospheric
administration
had been listening to volcanic activity
in the southern pacific ocean
the sound was unlike anything they had
ever heard
some begin to speculate that the noise
originated from some
unknown animal but for an animal to be
able to make such a loud noise
it would have had to have been enormous
christopher fox who worked for the
n-o-double-a at the time
was interviewed by david woleman on the
extraordinarily loud noise
which emanated from the depths this is a
text excerpt from the interview
fox's hunch is that the sound nickname
bloop is most likely
to come from some sort of animal because
its signature
is a rapid variation in frequency
similar to that of sounds
known to be made by marine beast there's
one crucial difference however
in 1997 bloop was detected by sensors up
to 4 800 kilometers
3 000 miles apart that means that it
must be far
louder than any whale noise or any other
animal noise for that matter
is it even remotely possible that some
creature bigger than any whale
is lurking in the ocean depths the sound
became the subject of wild speculation
and eventually some
connected an eerie dot as i said in low
crafts the call of cthulhu the horror
is here on earth asleep beneath the
ocean
and there is more the source of the
mysterious bloop
was triangulated to approximately 50
degrees
longitude and 100 degrees latitude a
remote area in the southern pacific
ocean an eerie fact for the fans of the
work of lovecraft
for you see cthulhu sleeps dead dreaming
at relay
a sunken underwater city in a remote
place
within the southern pacific ocean had
lovecraft been prescient
had cthulhu called out from his city
heralding his return
preparing to rise forth to reclaim the
earth which was his to rule
well no it took about 10 years but the
scientists
did finally discover that the origin of
the bloop was
cracking sea ice not as dramatic but a
huge relief for most of us
but although the bloop was not actually
the sound of cthulhu
calling up from his undersea city the
fear that the sound of the bloop invokes
is a part of the true horror that
cthulhu represents
the most merciful thing in the world i
think
is the inability of the human mind to
correlate all its contents
we live in a placid island of ignorance
in the midst of black seas of infinity
and it was not meant that we should
voyage far
the sciences each straining in its own
direction have hitherto harmed us little
but someday the piecing together of
dissociated knowledge will open up such
terrifying vistas of reality
and of our frightful position therein
that we shall either go mad from the
revelation or flee from the deadly light
into the peace and safety of a new dark
age
what do we really know about the
universe
about our own world even since the dawn
of mankind
oceans have been a source of mystery awe
and terror
the ocean could bring life or death
it could smash apart ships swallow up
cities
bringing storms that turn the sky the
color of blood
the ocean is often personified in
stories as the dwelling place of divine
beings
or as a divine being itself there are
many examples of this from
poseidon of greek mythology to manin of
celtic mythology
gods in the work of lovecraft however
are different from gods as they appear
in the vast majority of mythologies
for one they are not truly gods but
they are being so great so beyond us
that we can only call them divine in
mythology
gods are often wrathful appeased by
sacrificed fueled by belief though
many worship the gods of lovecraft's
universe
their worship is in vain for humankind
is not
significant we are ants to them less
than
ants the implication in the call of
cthulhu is that one day
cthulhu will rise and when he does we
cannot stop him
we can only bend to his will cthulhu
represents the fear of something
horrible in the future something
inevitable that cannot be stopped
you may not know when just that it is
coming and horrors await
um i think this is the right way i don't
remember this hallway though
oh god i think i'm lost oh man maybe i
should have listened to quinn
wait what am i saying i hate that guy i
want candy i gotta get the heck out of
this place
oh what's this weird ouija board
oh it looks just like that weird ugly
statue that quinn's playing with in the
other room
what is your pleasure sir
i am called mr haldy
well you can talk what are you doing in
here what is this weird place
this is my place of course i am a teller
of stories and a collector
i hope that you i don't care about any
of this i just want to get out of this
place and get my freedom
very well you must ask the ouija
luigi boy what kind of question should i
ask the ouija board i don't know what to
say
you have only to speak and you will know
how do i
escape this
b r
i n g
bring u s us
q u
i in
in
[Music]
ringo's quinn this doesn't feel right
what is this place where are you why why
do i feel like i can't move
what are you what's happening i feel
like
you will do for now
[Music]
hp lovecraft's the call of cthulhu is
set in the year 1926.
a man named francis waylon thurston has
been left with all of his uncle's things
after the man's sudden and unexplained
death and he soon begins to piece
together a terrible secret
it begins with the discovery of a box
containing old news clippings
notes and letters from the professor as
well as a peculiar and eerie baa relief
depicting a terrifying
vaguely humanoid monster all of the
items seem to relate to a mysterious
near unpronounceable phrase cthulhu
fatagen
the bar relief was made of clay and
appeared to have been
carved recently the flat carving
depicted a winged creature with a
tentacled face
and bat like wings waylon comes to
discover that the bar relief
had been carved by a young artist who
had seen the image in his dreams
he had brought the idol to the professor
in the hope that
he could possibly identify it and by the
most
unusual of coincidences the professor
actually did recognize the image as well
as the phrase
the young man had heard in his dreams
cthulhu
he had first come into contact with the
strange phrase
and grisly image nearly 20 years earlier
in the year 1908 that year the american
archaeological society of which my uncle
excuse me the characters uncle had been
a part of
received a visit from a man named john
raymond lagrasse
a police inspector he brought with him a
bizarre green stone
sculpture not unlike
this one i guess it's made of some
strange stone that no one recognizes
it's got runes all over it that no one
can decipher
it was found among some strange cult in
new orleans
i mean not this one of course the one
from the story now you have to
understand
the archaeologists got very excited
about the statue
though it was very clearly ancient the
stone was unplaceable
and the language indecipherable
the characters along the base were
equally baffling
and no member present despite a
representation of half the world's
expert
learning in the field could form the
least
notion of even their remotest linguistic
kinship
they like the subject and material
belong to something
horribly remote and distinct from
mankind
as we know it something frightfully
suggestive
of old and unhallowed cycles of life
in which our world and our conceptions
have no part
the statue was a complete anomaly
they are all completely baffled
except for one man out of all of the
archaeologists in the room
only one man knew anything about what
they were looking at
a man named william channing webb
nearly 50 years earlier he had
encountered something similar
during a tour of greenland in search of
runic inscriptions
it was there that he encountered the
cult
there was little much known of this cult
among the
other inuit natives there they spoke of
it in hushed tones
saying that it had come down from some
terribly ancient
eons before the earth was even formed
the cult engaged in nameless rites
involving human sacrifice and performed
strange hereditary rituals which
they addressed to some supreme elder
devil
the story uses the inuit name tonasuk
in reference to this supreme devil
in the inuit religion tornasuk is a very
powerful sky god
the leader of the tornad a group of
protective gods
he is also sometimes described as a
mischievous demon spirit
which in the real world was known to be
worshiped by way of offering in
greenland
and even in the northern eastern parts
of north america
william channing webb recognized the
statue because the cult
he had encountered in greenland had
danced around a crude by relief
depicting the same entity and the words
in which the inuit cult had chanted
were the same words the new orleans cult
had chanted
the direct translation being in his
house
at relay dead cthulhu waits
dreaming the natives of the louisiana
swamps had called
for the police though the cult has
presumably always worshipped there
something was different now the natives
were in the grip of
unimaginable terror they spoke a voodoo
and darker things
drums beat from deep within the black
woods
into which none dared venture though
several of their women and children had
gone missing
the wild screams and chants could be
heard through the night
and a hellfire blazed in the distance
twenty police set out into the woods
which hid the light of day by the time
they reached the cult it was night
the region they had ventured into was
known to be an evil place the natives
would come no further
into that place of hideous worship there
was said to be a black lake there
and within it a great formless being
worshiped by the cult and the winged
things which flew up from black caverns
within the earth
to look upon it was death it had been
there before men
and even before the beast of the woods
it was nightmare itself and to see it
was to die
but it made men dream and so they knew
enough to keep away
the cult members at least 100 of them
worshiped at the fringe of this evil
place
producing inhuman noises which chilled
the bones
as they echoed through the forest the
horror of the place overtook the men as
soon as they saw it
the cult members danced around a flame
circle surrounding a stone pillar
at the top of the pillar sat the strange
stone statue
there were dead men the missing natives
impaled upon
wooden stakes surrounding the horrific
circle
one of the policemen joseph d galvez
even swore that he could hear the
beating of enormous wings
just overhead hidden in the darkness
and could hear a great inhuman voice
call out in response to the ritual as
the terrible luminous
eyes stared out once the madness was
settled
47 of the cult members were captured and
interrogated
according to the cult members they
worshipped
the great old ones beings of enormous
power who lived
eons before men ever walked the world
they came to the young earth from beyond
the sky
those old ones were gone now inside the
earth
under the sea but their dead bodies had
told their
secrets and dreams to the first men who
formed the cult which had never died
this was that cult and the prisoner said
it had always existed and always
would exist hidden in distant waist and
dark places
all over the world until the time when
the great priest cthulu
from his dark house in the mighty city
of relay under the waters
should rise and bring the earth again
beneath his sway
someday he would call when the stars
were ready
and the secret cult would always be
waiting to liberate him
you see mankind was not alone amongst
the intelligent beings of the universe
and perhaps
beside beings of such magnitude mankind
cannot even be considered intelligent
the figure depicted on the statue was
indeed cthulhu
the great priest the item was made of no
known earthly stone because it did not
come from
earth for when the old ones came to this
small world
they brought their images with them the
primary form of communication for these
beings was the language of thought
though by the time men arrived on earth
they slept within their ancient city
they still could whisper through the
void
and influence the minds of mortal men it
was how they led the first men to their
hidden images
it was how they inspired the old
religion
and gave them the rituals and spells
which could reawaken them when the time
was right
for eons it went on this way the old
ones
dead dreaming in their strange city
until one day
something happened which cut off the
connection
the great city of relay where the old
ones slept
maintained by the spells of the great
cthulhu
sank beneath the waves
the primordial mysterious earthly waters
blocked the voices of the old ones from
reaching mortal men
but the cult never forgot they kept the
old ways
hidden in the shadowy corners of the
world waiting
knowing that one day the stars would
realign
and the time would be right again to
awaken the ones who slept beneath the
waters
but there was another secret the cult
kept
one which they would dare not utter it
was said that other things
shapes out of the darkness had come up
to visit the faithful
they flew up from black caverns within
the earth
and carried twisted rumors of things to
come
most of the information the men were
able to extract came from one man
named castro he claimed to have spoken
to elder members of the cult in china
undying ones who possessed ancient
knowledge
they knew of the beings from the stars
who had not been entirely made of flesh
and blood that had inhabited the earth
beforehand and left behind the arts
which could revive them when the time
was right
it was said that to herald their coming
the earth would fall
into chaos violence and ecstasy
every man killing and taking pleasure
for his own sake
in the distant corners of the world the
cult kept those old ways
so the great old ones are serious
business basically and the cult has kept
the knowledge of them and how to revive
them when the time is right basically
forever
since the dawn of mankind itself now
that's some pretty ancient knowledge
and then there's the necronomicon a book
in lovecraft's universe written by the
mad arab abdul azeroth
they contain all sorts of information on
eldritoras
how to communicate with them and how to
summon them it also supposedly contained
dark magic spells
honestly it kind of reminds me of some
of these old books that my
uncle left me but magic isn't real in
any way these books are
[Music]
blank no all of these books were
they were blank i i swear it
magic isn't real anyway i guess it never
hurts to try i
why mean it's not like anything bad's
gonna happen
let's see here this one looks
interesting to invoke
ancient power i call forth
through space and time through shadow at
night
through earth and sea claim what is old
claim what is bound
[Music]
well what was that it must have been
organism9186 somewhere
yeah that that's what that was anyway
that's enough of all of this
back to the call of cthulhu
so basically the purpose of this cult is
to help the great old ones wake up
when the time is right and then cthulhu
and the rest of them would be free to do
what they do
which is what exactly
no one ever asks this question what is
it that the great old ones are doing
so we know that the old ones including
cthulhu are cosmic beings
they are bound to cosmic will when the
stars are right they can leap from world
to world
but when the stars are wrong they could
not live
cthulhu is called the great priest and
it is said that his spells are the ones
which preserve the old ones and relate
until the time was right it also says
that the old ones aren't dormant but in
fact
communicate with each other from within
their tombs
through thought though the religion of
the cult members was merely
a utilitarian effort on the part of the
old ones
the fact that cthulhu performs spells
implies that they themselves
are appealing to a grander cosmic
authority
and so does the fact that they are
extremely subject to cosmic alignment
and the idea that they are described as
dead dreaming
almost implies that they are all
collectively engaged in some sort of
great prayer reaching out to
greater powers even beyond them
now great cthulhu does make an
appearance in this short story
the cult ultimately failed to complete
its cold
but all the same cthulhu had been
released
by lost sailors on a stormy sea
for whatever reason the stars had been
just right
the great city of relay rose up from its
watery grave
and the spectral intercourse of the gods
was reconnected with those who inhabit
the earth
the cult heard it the shadowed ones and
caverns beneath the earth
heard it poor young wilcox had heard it
too
and several others from which my uncle
dang it
the character uncle interviewed
they heard the call of cthulhu
and while the cult celebrated the coming
of a new age
the rest if anything saw a maddening
dream
of a terrible city and poor wilcox had
been briefly driven insane
but for whatever the reason this was not
the right time
this had only been a temporary blip in
the cosmic cycle the stars moved again
and the great city of relay sunk back
into the ocean
taking cthulhu and the rest of the great
old ones with it
perhaps these events only herald what is
to come
cthulhu and the rest of the old ones
will wake up one day
and we will not be able to stop them
and i think right there gets down to the
very core
of why cthulhu is really scary
as i said earlier cthulhu represents the
fear of something
to come that is unstoppable
if we could consider the first humans
who ever lived
i know impossible humans exist upon a
continuum
but just do this thought experiment with
me consider
the first humans they would live and
have no knowledge of death
until they saw it once one of them died
they would have been forced to face the
terrible truth
that the blackness and stillness of
death waited for them all
so much of what life is involves staving
off death
we must constantly intake air find food
avoid dangers
all to slow down the inevitable but
death will come to claim us all
just as cthulhu will come to claim his
earthly realm
death seems to be one of the primary
fears amongst conscious beings
because we are aware of the fact that
our bodies will cease to
be functional one day we have created
countless different ideas about how our
consciousness could potentially exist
after death believing in an afterlife or
reincarnation makes it easier for a lot
of people
to deal with the fact that they will die
if you rise again after death
like the great old ones rising again
after the changing of the stars
then death is not really death but not
all of the ideas that humans have
created about
the afterlife necessarily depict a
positive
picture of what's on the other side to
me one of the most
terrifying ideas about the afterlife
is hell
[Music]
[Music]
will bring you
[Music]
the bible describes a lake of fire
but it wasn't until dante's divine
comedy
that the modern idea of hell was born
the divine comedy depicts a man's
journey through hell
limbo and the heavenly realm
midway upon the journey of our life i
found myself within a forest
dark for the straightforward pathway
had been lost dante
led by his guide journeys through the
nine circles of inferno
passing the condemned undying sinners
along the way
in each circle the sinners are forced to
endure different torments
at the hands of demons within the ninth
circle of hell waited satan himself
the idea of eternal torment is a
terrifying one
to me personally the idea of eternity
itself is terrifying
that gets back into another lovecraft
idea actually
humans are finite beings inherently
limited
our conception of reality is linear we
move
forward in time we see things in terms
of beginning middle and
end i've been of the opinion for a long
time now that the greatest mysteries in
our universe
are beyond our understanding when
someone stares into the eyes of an
eldritch horror in a lovecraft story and
goes completely mad upon witnessing
it lovecraft is playing with this idea
it is a being so complex so beyond our
concept of reality
that our minds sometimes simply break
when we encounter them
stephen king plays with this in what i
consider to be his homage to lovecraft
the book it one of the biggest
misconceptions about
stephen king's it is that the monster is
a clown
it's not a clown the clown is one of
the infinite forms in which this
creature could potentially take
it came to earth long ago
long before there were any humans it
slept and waited for millions of years
beneath the town that would one day be
dairy because it knew that one day it
would have
rich food in which to feast upon
humans which could envision terrors
beyond anything
possible for non-intelligent beings
it possessed a true form which was
unknowable to mortal sight
and to stare into its shining eyes
illuminated by the dead lights flowing
from the cosmic macroverse out of which
it was born
was to be maddened when they
got here it would cast them shrieking
insane
into the dead lights
this idea of cosmic madness is
definitely one that lovecraft
popularized
and this very famous trope of course
makes an appearance in the call of
cthulhu as well
i mentioned that the great priest
himself does make an appearance in this
short story
though some of the men who encounter
cthulhu escape
some of them go mad at the instant they
lay eyes upon him
i think the idea that there are things
in existence not meant for humans
relates back to the quote from the
beginning of the video
we live on a placent island of ignorance
and it was not meant that we should
voyage far it suggests that there is
some truth that we
simply should not be aware of some
things that we
simply should not see
trollian hear these words for i shall
only speak them once there is awesome
grandeur in the cosmic cycle
humankind is insignificant the psycho
will exist without you
you scared me where have you been all
this time tell me quinn
have you practiced the magic in those
spell books
yeah but i can't seem to get the spells
to work i guess my magic is pretty weak
to unleash the full potential you must
first awaken the power inside of you
yeah and how do you know it is written
in the necronomicon
how do you know about the necronomicon i
thought you hated reading
other your questions no more i have
found the spell that you need
[Music]
awakening spell okay it doesn't look
too hard i guess we could give it
another try
let's do it
in this shadow night in this dark hour
we summon now the ancient powers
hear us ruler of the deeps serpent of
the black seas
rise and commune with me lend me your
power yes yes keep chanting priest of
old dark lord of cuba i beseech thee
awaken you're the one awakening oh my
god
[Music]
whoa i can do magic i feel
strong i feel powerful i feel
wrong like there's something inside me
ah something dark
this is what you wanted the power of the
gods no this isn't right
i know i don't want this you are our
vessel our what do you mean our
what are you talking about organism i am
no longer organism9186
he was easy to possess but you have
always
been surprisingly strong for years we
have waited for a vessel in which to
place our dark lord
and now it is nearly complete your uncle
hid you from us
and now we have you there is only one
task yet to be done
the darkness but he can't live
whilst your will remains strong i am
afraid we will have to purify the vessel
by killing and releasing your pathetic
mortal soul
so that the dark one can finally make
full use of that body
no
oh stop at the hotel
[Music]
you are the vessel quinn must die for
the garland can live
look the stars are right
no please no i promise i will tell
anybody about the cult
you can find another vessel i'll help
you i have four brothers you can take
any one of them
[Music]
[Music]
well that was terrifying what are you
talking about that was great
you really do like to see me suffer
don't you lighten up it was just a
simulation
well i guess you're right at least we
know now what it would be like if
lovecraftian beings actually existed in
the real world
yeah that was fun hey since it's
halloween we should watch a spooky
lovecraft movie to celebrate
yeah i don't know organism i'm kind of
lovecrafted out and plus there's like no
good lovecraft adaptations
well what about that lovecraft country
show well lovecraft country is actually
based off of this book by matt ruff
it's kind of a weird horror anthology
but it's only tangentially related to
h.p lovecraft's work
i did a review on the book and it was
kind of an intense experience for me so
i'm not really ready to jump into the
show yet
well i heard the color out of space with
nikola's cage was pretty cool oh please
do not get me started on that garbage
i have never been so shocked by the lack
of plot in a film
also nicholas cage screaming about his
alpacas the entire movie
no thanks two thumbs down well there's
gotta be some good left crap related
movies or shows you like
well there is the lighthouse starring
willem dafoe and robert pattinson
i really liked it it has a bunch of fire
of the gods ideas in there you know like
prometheus and such
you have a young man and an old man
working at this lighthouse
now the older man does not allow the
younger man to operate the lighthouse
he is concealing the illumination just
as the gods
concealed fire from mankind in greek
mythology and there's also some pretty
cool lovecraft concepts thrown in
it's a pretty intense movie
interestingly enough
it's actually based off of a short story
by edgar allen poe at least
loosely who is one of lovecraft's major
influences
yeah i don't want to watch that two
dudes in a lighthouse that sounds lame
and it's in black and white black and
white films are lame well i guess you
wouldn't like annihilation then
what's it about well it's based off of
this book by jeff
vandermeer four scientists go into this
area that's being affected by this weird
object that's fallen from space
many people who go within the area lose
track of time and kind of go mad
it's basically it's basically a way
better adaptation of the color out of
space than nicolas cage's stupid
adaptation
without even being an actual adaptation
and also there's
a really cool looking mutant bear in the
movie well that sounds awesome
why wouldn't i like it the main
characters are women
all of them yes but you said it was a
good movie you know organism i just
don't think i'm up to watching a movie
right now i think i'm gonna go read
horror stories
i have a new anthology to crack open
actually uh yeah the simulation was cool
it's a good thing that none of that
stuff is real though see you later
it's a good thing none
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you